[Music]
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between pizza hut in japan and lewis
this is food wars
in japan a pizza hut pizza comes in
three sizes the smallest comes in a my
box order and is approximately 15
centimeters
[Music]
our small can only be made on a
gluten-free crust
check it out looks like something you
would get in your high school cafeteria
and it measures 10 inches or 25.4
centimeters our next size up is a medium
which is 26 centimeters
[Music]
i'm gonna take this little guy
this pizza is so good dude
and our large pizza is 14 inches or 35.5
centimeters
this my box pizza deal includes fries
and chicken nuggets for 1080 yen or at a
basket cheesecake for
1290 yen
or
get three my boxes for
three thousand yen and you can get a
free style menu item like a 1.5 liters
of coca-cola also for those wanting a
little alcohol you can get a my box deal
with an alcoholic beverage for
1100 yen it's called
being tipsy
[Music]
now we're going to the boxes baby
our next size up is a 13 dinner box it
is a medium one topping pizza bread
sticks and cinnamon sticks this is the
best idea if i had to go into an office
this would be my briefcase that's what
is what i take to work every day
now you're probably thinking huh joe i
want more food in a box well pizza hut
of course has you covered with the big
dinner box um
oh it is the big dinner box this is
two one topping pizzas with wings or
breadsticks that's what i got of course
you could also get pasta and breadsticks
you can also get kaypapas and
breadsticks or just a third pizza all
for 23.99 to 24.99 man dinner is served
you can get chicken on the wall
in two pieces four pieces and eight
pieces that's really cute japan two
wings in the u.s our wing orders start
at 6 12 18 and the biggest order you can
get 36.
well that's that's the hottest wing
street you gotta hire a spice expert
because this is nothing dude i've had
spicier lacroix
here is a japan large basic pizza
we call our cheese pizza basic and it is
2030 yen or
18.39 cents us and it has a surface area
of 754.77
square centimeters so that is about
0.024
or
2.63 yen per square centimeter the u.s
large cheese pizza is 13.99
or
1544 japanese yen it has a surface area
of 989.9
square centimeter which breaks down to
.014 cents per square centimeter or 1.54
japanese yen much cheaper here in the us
so here are two large basic pizzas this
one right here is hand tossed dough and
this one right here is a palm pizza here
are two large u.s cheese pizzas one of
them has the pancreas and one of them
has the hand toss crust both are the
same size and the same price we want to
find out which gives you more pizza for
your money
let's weigh a slice of each and compare
go
[Music]
so winner is
ham toss no
oh wow that's like that's crazy how good
i did just here
same price 25 more pizza
[Music]
look at this
here's everything you can get at
japanese pizza hat you cannot get in the
us and here is everything you get at a
u.s pizza you can't get in japan makes
consume pizzas okay
so i got everything on here in half and
half and a medium size
on hand tossed grass all right so let's
start with this one so i got this tokuma
bulgogi tokuguma means special delicious
so it's special delicious bugagi and
this one is menta potato mayo bacon
menta means spicy cut roll and it looks
good
so next one we've got double shrimp with
special lobster sauce and this one is
ground barbecue asparagus bacon and this
one is potato sausage mayo
next one we've got crumbling
food
pork and next one spicy pulled pork
selected cheese and thick cut iberico
and this one is super supreme mexican
carapeno kara means it's like spicy so
spicy jalapeno on there and next one is
snappy potato sausage and this one is
green and yellow veggie pizza shrimp
mayo mentai seafood and this one is
addictive anchovy and black olive first
exclusive us pizza pizzas this one right
here is the meat lover's pizza look at
this thing you see that this thing is
pepperoni italian sausage ham
bacon seasoned pork and beef that's
every meat that's every meat in the
store i think uh this one right here is
the hawaiian chicken pizza this
looks like one bite would like send me
to my grave this at least has a
vegetable on it
and the green peppers were a mistake
this one right here chicken bacon
parmesan
chicken bacon tomatoes and a parmesan
crust oh yeah dude look at the crust on
this they make the cheese right in the
crust i just love that pizza it's like
we gotta cover the every surface with
cheese god forbid
you can take a bite doesn't have cheese
in it
in japan you can get a pizza with four
different topping areas called the four
series so let's start with this one
it's called gochisso4 gochiso means
feast
and next one we've got bulgogi festa 4
so let's move on to the next one we've
got
numbers four lovers
what
is this for this beef it's gonna be
horrible
and this one is called kodawari 4
kudavari means authentic
and this one in front of me is gourmet
mania 4
what did i do to you pizza hut it's
burnt
look at this
all right next one
and the last one is classic or this is
classic
this one right here the backyard
barbecue pizza barbecue sauce instead of
pizza sauce i think and it comes with a
barbecue honey shall i i think i shall
oh yeah i think i'm gonna like this
don't sleep on the pizza at honey
barbecue this is really good i think
this is buffalo chicken pizza
tangy buffalo sauce
exact opposite problem i think the sauce
ruins this too strong skip the sauce so
this one right here is a japan only
pizza so this is a pizza with a
sausage crust with bulgogi teriyaki
chicken
camembert cheese gouda cheese green
chili sauce shrimp squid tuna mayo
broccoli
corn basil sauce and
anchovies too much but let's give it a
try look at this
it's too much
[Music]
it's disgusting
in the first place
i hate anchovies
don't put anchovies
it's just
muzzy i picked out that pizza for you
george sorry my man gotta do it for the
show here is the usa only pizza it is a
pizza with toppings and sauces and
cheeses you can only get in the u.s and
not in japan first got the gluten-free
crust remember that that really sad
looking crust uh we can have a creamy
garlic parmesan barbecue or buffalo
sauce as a base i went with the creamy
garlic parmesan got meatballs banana
peppers and for the crust i pretty sure
i want the garlic parmesan
[Music]
it's not awful
when you order food and you're like
really hungry so something sounds like
it's gonna be really good but then we
start eating you're like i think i
screwed up this is definitely like
descriptive
so here we've got japan's exclusive size
we've got chicken nuggets and this is
four pieces eight pieces 16 pieces and
we also have plain flavor and spicy
flavor let's try this
please
this is
everything is plain
spicy very spicy nuggets
and next one we've got honey cheese
balls so cheese balls there and we've
got honey syrup so next one we've got
japanese style pasta chicken so this
chicken is marinated in soy sauce and
rolled in potato starch instead of wheat
flour and deep fried let's talk about
u.s exclusive sides can't get these in
japan pizza hut also got pasta referred
to at one point is pasta hut you can get
two of these baked pastas at our pizza
huts one is the tosca toscani
what
what'd i say
fine no tuscany is to us and why they
sell this one with t-u-s-c-a-n-i
no come on i'm looking it up keep
rolling
now with pizza hut get a family-sized
tuscany pasta
in your face
just an absolute abuse of italian
culture here is the tuscany chicken
alfredo pasta and the toscani meaty
marinara pasta if i can't put a fine
enough point on it i do not want to eat
this at all this looks like a tv dinner
like this is what you eat in your
apartment sitting on a folding chair one
light bulb hanging from the ceiling
eating this just right out of the oven
staring at a wall looking at like
cockroaches running up and down your one
window has a view of a brick wall the
calendar on the walls from three years
ago nobody wants this
kpops what are kpop as you ask i don't
know
they've got jalapenos and stuff in them
so they're kind of like spicy tater tots
these to me are like quintessential
pizza hut sides we got breadsticks and
we got cheese sticks they both come with
the marinara sauce we also have a
marinara sauce you guys don't have
sauce talk so here
is extra sauces so if you want you can
get green chili sauce or
honey syrup so the wing street wings you
can get a pizza hut also come in
exclusive flavors you can't get in japan
here are all the sauces
spicy garlic is really good joe's sauce
seal of approval teriyaki this seems
like a no-brainer but we're not gonna
leave it to chance
no
that's not correct this is terrible
doesn't pass garlic parmesan oh look
there's like parmesan like on top of it
[Laughter]
that might be the best one
lemon pepper dry rub why
do i have to apply it
yeah i'm not into that man i don't get
it i know what drake's going on about
man lemon pepper's not very good crucify
me internet i don't like lemon pepper
dry rub wings should i i think maybe i
should be rubbing it that's what i'm
doing wrong
is that too much
whoops yep you're right too much
that's good also sauces real quick we
got blue cheese we got ranch
so here is japan's exclusive desserts
here we've got basque cheesecake we've
got lady burton vanilla ice cream
and last one we've got lady burton
chocolate ice cream desserts we got him
in the u.s you can get yourself this a
set of six cinnabon cinnamon rolls this
is the
triple chocolate brownie i'm starting to
lose it guys all that pizza it just hit
me this right here is the ultimate
chocolate chip cookie this is pretty
funny they should cut this like a pizza
cinnamon sticks they also come with a
thing of icing
maybe my obituary photo
i can't believe how good that is this is
the cinnabon thing i want to try it now
since i had it before i want to see that
compares to that
cinnabon is still better
in japan our fountain drinks are
coca-cola products in the u.s our soft
drinks are pepsi products you know what
that means
this is soda wars
in japan we have
coke
coke zero
and fountain grape and green tea
and cool
cool orange juice look at this face
cool
it has light orange taste
classic pepsi
cherry pepsi diet pepsi orange oh yeah
crushed right yeah orange crush mountain
dew and of course sierra mist which is
like mountain dew only
so much worse
so a full pizza is
2256 calories
112.8
of your daily recommended value
too many calories
in the u.s our large cheese pan pizza
has eight slices and each slice is 360
calories so for the total pizza that's 2
80 calories that's 144
of your daily calories and both the fat
and the sodium are each over 200 percent
of your daily allowance japan's large
pepperoni spring with plump bread crust
is 228 calories per slice or
2736 calories for the entire thing which
is 136.8
percent of your daily calories
even more calories
this is a large us pepperoni with the
pan crust that's a thick guy
one slice 370 calories that makes the
whole pizza 2
930 calories and that is 146.5
of your daily allowance now i would like
to point out that the large pepperoni
pizza is the most popular pizza hut
pizza in the u.s but not japan online it
rakes about the 14th most popular in
japan one of the pizzas we enjoy is the
seafood mix
it's one of pizza hut's best sellers for
over 20 years wow
the japan's most calorific pizza is the
large toku uma bulgogi and i forgot to
order large tokuma bulgogi sorry about
that but this one is toku uma bulgoti
and this one is smaller but large sliced
pizza is
285 calories which makes the entire
lunch pizza on plum breadcrust
3420 calories
3420 calories
in the u.s our most calorific pizza is
the meat lovers i also was supposed to
get the large this is a medium if
someone graphics could just make this
pizza much bigger or me much smaller one
slice is 470 calories making the total
pizza which should be eight slices
3760 calories that's more than double
your daily fat and triple your daily
sodium i am a glutton for punishment but
i'm not going to bite into this pizza it
looks like a knife
there's a few ingredients to watch out
for at the pizza huts in the u.s one is
an ingredient found in our salad
croutons it is called
[Music]
azodicarbonamide
azo azodika
[Music]
or ada it is a substance used for making
vinyl foam plastics for things like yoga
mats and it's also in our croutons i'm
not quite sure why the use of this
additive surprisingly enough is not
permitted in japan what
that's just horrible
both yoga mats and salads have a
connection to health but u.s salad
proteins have actually plastic yoga mat
plastic
how ironic
also in the u.s you're going to want to
watch out for yellow number five aka
tartrazine which appears in these
cinnabon mini rolls oops already ate one
according to the european union this
chemical quote may have an adverse
effect on activity and attention in
children and quote it is banned in the
eu it's not banned here in america and
it is at least not allowed at any of the
pizza huts in japan totally you can
totally get this here in america
let's get some deficit on that attention
may have adverse effect on activity and
tension in children i mean it's having a
horrible effect on my attention as an
adult
i stopped paying attention to what was
coming out of my mouth moments ago so
the do got yellow number five as well
orange crush has yellow number six and
red number 40. remember those are bad
too
all the color things are bad
i have to say this is also terrible why
the hell american fast food chains put
harmful chemicals into their foods
do they make their food in a chemistry
laboratory or something
use the kitchen
hey if you're new to food wars hello we
actually have a whole another series
where we compare the us and the uk you
can watch every one of those episodes
right now click the floating box near my
head